good morning everyone
foreign minister dr ahmed and i uh have
just had a very
productive meeting i was particularly
delighted to
welcome him i wanted to welcome you
to washington and to return the
hospitality that you and their
highnesses the amir and the crown prince
showed me in kuwait last july
we've been on the phone many times since
but there is nothing to replace
uh person-to-person dialogue uh no
substitute for the kind of discussion
that we're able to have today
uh here in washington
uh this meeting today was the
culmination of the fifth u.s kuwait
strategic dialogue with nearly a week of
intensive discussions
between our teams
and it's another demonstration of our
enduring commitment to strong
partnerships across the gulf region uh
this year marks the seventh decade of
diplomatic ties between our countries
starting shortly after kuwait became an
independent nation we also recently
marked as i think everyone knows the
30th anniversary of operations desert
shield and desert storm when the united
states led a coalition of 35 countries
that brought an end to the gulf war and
liberated kuwait
and when it came time to end the war in
afghanistan
kuwait stood with the united states
you help us evacuate thousands of people
american citizens
foreign nationals
afghans providing flights medical care
clothing even toys for kids
because of kuwait's help
thousands of people reach safety and
afghan families have been able to start
new lives around the world
this was a signal
of kuwait's generosity and your
commitment to humanitarianism
and international stability
and we see that in the leadership role
that kuwait plays in institutions like
the gulf cooperation council
and the arab league
we see it in how you strive to help
resolve conflicts like in yemen for
which you've hosted peace talks
and you've helped significantly reduce
the threat that daesh poses to
international security even as we remain
very vigilant about the ongoing threat
and just last year
we saw this statementship in full force
when
kuwaiti mediation helped heal a rift
that had divided countries in the gulf
region for years
uh the work of mediation and peacemaking
never ends
we both know that we spoke a lot about
that today and i especially appreciated
our close consultations today on issues
that quite literally span the globe
we talked about the ongoing security
challenge posed by russia's provocations
and threatened aggression toward ukraine
we agree that this crisis is much bigger
than just ukraine or even europe
it's a serious concern to the entire
international community it requires an
international response
kuwait knows this in a sense
better than anyone because at stake
in in ukraine are some of the most basic
principles of international relations
that undergird peace and security
like the principle that one nation can't
simply change the borders of another by
force
uh or seek to dominate its decisions
uh subjugate it to its will in a sphere
of influence
we just spoke a moment ago
about the liberation of kuwait
now 31 years ago so kuwait understands
these principles very very well
we discussed iran the united states
appreciates kuwait's support
for a mutual return to compliance with
the jcpoa the iran nuclear agreement
because it's the most effective way to
ensure that iran cannot develop a
nuclear weapon
we're very grateful for kuwait's close
coordination through venues like the gcc
iran working group where we have stood
together against iran's destabilizing
actions in the region
and we talked about our shared goal of
advancing peace and security for
israelis and palestinians alike i thank
the foreign minister for coit's
commitment to addressing the needs of
the palestinian people including through
financial assistance to the palestinian
authority
the partnership we have
is constantly evolving to meet new
challenges and we spoke about some of
them today our teams have been focused
on them as well over the past week
uh
to cite one new front where we are
joined together and working together uh
and that is the front of biological
threats
the pandemic is made clear to everyone
something that we repeat but uh is no
less fundamental for being repeated when
it comes to global health security none
of us are safe until all of us are safe
to that end kuwait in the united states
signed a memorandum of understanding to
prevent
to detect to prepare for outbreaks
caused by dangerous pathogens
under this partnership kuwait's ministry
of health and the united states will
share technical information and best
practices on disease surveillance we'll
meet regularly along with other
participating gcc countries to share
this knowledge more widely in the region
so that collectively we're better
prepared
to respond to future pandemics
these efforts build on the work our
countries are already doing to stop this
pandemic and i want to thank kuwait
again for the vital role that
it's been playing in the kobit 19
response
generous support to institutions like
the world health organization kovacs
are making a difference in providing
safe and effective vaccines around the
world
this level of collaboration between our
countries is possible only because of
the strong bonds that have been built
together
over the decades
forged in war
strengthened in peace
we have strong defense ties
weight has long hosted u.s forces our
military has worked together in many
ways including by conducting exercises
and training together
the united states is committed to
supporting courageous military uh with
assistance as well as through commercial
sales
we have strong economic ties our
bilateral trade relationship now amounts
to more than 4.5 billion dollars a year
and we hope that figure will grow even
more in the years ahead as we find new
opportunities to work together in areas
like sustainable infrastructure and
renewable energy
we share a commitment to freedom of
religion and belief and our countries
have worked together to advance that
freedom both bilaterally and in
international institutions
and finally
the beating heart of the relationship
is our people-to-people ties
nearly ten thousand kuwaitis choose to
study in the u.s
or universities
english language institutes every single
year
thousands of other kuwaitis and people
of kuwaiti descent live in the united
states and tens of thousands of
americans live in kuwait
these family culture